باي باي.
اسمعني يا بوتين. نحن مستعدون
لتقديم الضمانات التي تريدها.
فلتوقف حربك يا رجل. هكذا خاطب
ماكرون بوتين وحرب الحلفاء تندلع
وامريكا تقف ضد اوروبا والروس في
مدرجات المشاهدين يستمتعون
بالمشهد. بينما ذكريات الحرب
العالمية الاولى تعود للواجهة في
اوكرانيا والكرملين يفجر
المفاجأة. بوتين سيذهب الى ارض
المعركة الاوكرانية. واشنطن ترس
اسلحتها وجنودها بالقرب من روسيا
فكيف سيرد بوتين وتحركات مريبة
للروس رصدتها الاقمار الصناعية
والولايات المتحدة تعلن تحدي
الصين باسلحة اكثر فتكا فما هو
الرد الصيني واردوغان لن نتراجع
اطلاقا وبلادنا لن تركع. ما الذي
يتحدث عنه هذا العثماني وايران
تقطع احدى اذرعتها لارضاء
المتظاهرين. هدوء روسيا المخيف.
الهدوء الروسي لا يبشر بخير لدى
الاوكران. والغرب يخشى هدوء
روسيا الذي وبكل الاحوال يسبق
العاصفة. هنا تقرير لمايكروسوفت
يحذر من تنسيق موسكو لهجمات
الكترونية على البنية التحتية
الحيوية لاوكرانيا. واضاف
التقرير ان هذه الحملة يمكن ان
تكون نذيرا من روسيا بتوسيع نطاق
الالكترونية خارج حدود اوكرانيا.
مع التركيز على البلدان والشركات
التي تزود اوكرانيا بسلاسل
التوريد الحيوية للمساعدات
والاسلحة هذا الشتاء وذلك بحسب
بوليتكو. لتكشف صور الاقمار
الصناعية عن نشاط وتحركات روسية
قرب اوكرانيا مطار عسكري روسي
يبعد حوالي خمسمائة ميل من
الحدود الاوكرانية ينذر بهجوم
ويشكل منعطفا خطيرا بالحرب وذلك
حسب ديرش بيجل الالمانية. لتؤكد
الاستخبارات البريطانية ان
العاصفة الروسية قادمة بقولها ان
موسكو تتجه الى حصار باخمود في
دونيتسك وسط تحقيقها تقدما هناك.
حيث تحولت مدينة باخموت بشرق
اوكرانيا الى مستنقع دم مع ورود
انباء عن سقوط مئات القتلى
والجرحى يوميا في لم تتمكن فيه
القوات الروسية ولا الاوكرانية
من تحقيق تقدم كبير بعد شهور من
الاقتتال وفقا لصحيفة الجارديان.
وفي مشاهد شبيهة بالحرب العالمية
الاولى. صور لجنود اوكرانيين في
خنادق موحلة ومغمورة بالمياه.
فيما تتناثر جذوع الاشجار التي
قطعتها قذائف المدفعية على ساحات
القتال بحسب الصحيفة البريطانية.
حرب الخنادق الى تفاصيل المعارك.
اعلنت الدفاع الروسية اسقاط عشر
مسيرات ومروحية اوكرانية. اضافة
الى مقتل ستين جنديا اوكرانيا في
لتوقع روسيا وبلاروسيا اتفاقا
لضمان الامن الاقليمي بشأن تعديل
الاتفاقية المشتركة الموقعة عام
سبعة وتسعين بين الدولتين
والمرتبطة بتوفير الامن الاقليمي
المشترك في العسكري. هناك خرج
الرئيس الفرنسي مانويل ماكرون
ودعا الى منح روسيا ضمانات امنية
اذا عادت للتفاوض مؤكدا استمرار
دعمه لاوكرانيا عسكريا لكن
باسلحة لا تمكن كييف من ضرب
الاراضي الروسية بما يقحم فرنسا
بالصراع. القلق يتوسع ويزداد
ليصل الى بولندا. حيث وصلت معدات
عسكرية اليها والهدف تقوية
الروابط السياسية والحربية بين
الدول الحليفة. وبشأن التحالفات
تأتي هنا الخيانات. هكذا يقولها
الغرب نعم الرئيس التركي اردوجان
يصدم اوروبا ويعلن عن بدء
الانشاءات التمهيدية لمشروع مركز
استقبال واعادة ضخ الغاز الروسي
الى اوروبا لكن ما يخيف واشنطن
ويقلقها هو سعي موسكو المتزايد
لشراء من الاسلحة دقيقة التوجيه.
الا ان مديرة المخابرات
الامريكية توقعت تراجع وتيرة
القتال في اوكرانيا خلال الاشهر
القادمة لان الروس والاوكران
يستعدون لمعركة ما بعد الشتاء
بحسب قولها. ومن الحرب العسكرية
الى الحرب التجارية. قانون
مكافحة التضخم الامريكي يثير
خلافا مع اوروبا ومسؤول الماني
ينتقد السياسة لواشنطن محذرا من
حرب تجارية مع الولايات المتحدة
ليعلنها وزير الدفاع الامريكي
سنحدث ثالوثنا النووي برا وبحرا
وجوا وذلك ضمن الميزانية الجديدة
التي تقدر باربعة وثلاثين مليار
دولار. ليأتي هنا الرد الروسي.
اذ كشف الكرملين عن عزم الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين زيارة
منطقة دومباسا واقعة في شرق
اوكرانيا في الوقت المناسب والتي
تم ضمها نهاية سبتمبر الماضي.
فما الذي يخبئه بوتين بهذه
الزيارة وبين هذا وذاك خطة مسربة
من اربعة اجزاء وقعها الرئيس
الروسي بوتين تحدد كيف كان
سيتمكن جيشه من سحق سيطرة
اوكرانيا العسكرية واخضاعها خلال
عشرة ايام. لكن من الواضح ان
الامور لم تسر كما كان بعد نحو
عشرة اشهر من بدء الحرب وذلك وفق
مجلة يزويك. الصين شوكة يصعب
ابتلاعها. الحرب تشتعل ولكن من
تحت الرماد ليطلق عليها خبراء
السياسة العسكرية لقب الحرب
الباردة. امريكا لا ترضى ابدا
بالتقدم الصيني ولا ترضى بقبول
مكانتها. وزير الدفاع الامريكي
لويد استن المتحدة تبني قوة اكثر
فتكا في المحيطين الهندي والهادئ
كجزء من جهودها للتأكد من ان
الصين لا تهيمن على المنطقة
بالطريقة التي تنويها. واضاف
اوستن اسمحوا لي ان اكون واضحا
لن ندع ذلك يحدث. ووفقا لما
اوردته وكالة بلومبرج فان خطاب
اوستن يعد بمثابة طلقة تحذيرية
جديدة للرئيس الصيني حتى في وقت
تتطلع واشنطن فيه الى اقامة ما
تسميه حواجز حماية ومنع التوتر
مع الصين وعدم الخروج عن
السيطرة. من جانب اخر. قالت
مديرة المخابرات الامريكية ان
واشنطن لم ترى ما يفيد بتقديم
الصين المساعدات العسكرية لروسيا
الا ان الصينيين يواصلون العمل
مع روسيا على مجموعة متنوعة من
الاشياء والسعي لدعم في
المنتديات الدولية بحسب قولها.
فهل تستطيع واشنطن منع اصحاب
العيون الضيقة من هذه التحركات
المزعجة? تركيا ومعركة تكسير
العظام. عندما وجدت تركيا
الاجواء مهيئة لتحقيق اهدافها
وواشنطن قد فتحت الطريق امامها
وموسكو لم تعترض قالتها حكومة
انقرة باعلى صوتها. كل مواقع
الكردية في الشمال السوري اهداف
مشروعة للقوات التركية سواء كانت
قرب الحدود مع تركيا او بعيدة
عنها. واضافت الحكومة ان
التنظيمات الكردية تستغل تحالفها
مع واشنطن لشرعنة وجودها في
شمالي سوريا. ليعلنها اردوجان
بكل غرور. بلادنا لن تتراجع
اطلاقا عن الشريط الامني بعمق
ثلاثين كيلو مترا حدودنا
الجنوبية. مضيفا ان بلاده لم تعد
تركيا القديمة التي يتم تركيعها
حسب تعبيره. كما قال ايضا جاؤوا
من بعد الاف الكيلومترات ودعموا
المنظمات الارهابية قرب حدودنا.
في اشارة الى القوات الامريكية
في شمال سوريا. هناك اعلنت انقرة
استهدافها لسيارة تابعة لقوات
سوريا الديموقراطية بطائرة مسيرة
وبداية الغيث فكيف ستكون
النهاية? الاحداث والتطورات.
غارات للاحتلال الاسرائيلي على
مواقع للمقاومة في قطاع غزة. هذه
الغارات جاءت ردا على اطلاق
قذيفة من القطاع وكتائب القسام
تعلن استهداف دفاعاتها الجوية
لطائرات الاحتلال في سماء
القطاع. اجرى رئيس الكيان
الاسرائيلي اول زيارة رسمية الى
مملكة البحرين منذ تطبيع
العلاقات بين البلدين في عام
الفين وعشرين بحسب سي ان ان. الا
تستحون يا هؤلاء ايلون ماسك يسرب
ملفات سرية لتويتر قد تحرج ادارة
بايدن. المدعي العام الايراني
يعلن حل شرطة الاخلاق على خلفية
الاحتجاجات التي تشهدها البلاد
منذ وفاة الفتى ماسا اميني.
تقارير عن تلويح الحكومة
البريطانية بالاستعانة بالجيش في
مواجهة الاضرابات. بريطانيون في
صدمة. بلدية نيويورك تبحث عن
قاتل دموي براتب شهري يقدر بمئة
وسبعين الف دولار لقتل الجربان
بالمدينة. روسيا تستنسخ الطريقة
الصينية بالهدوء ثم الهدوء حتى
تنطلق العاصفة حينها لن يبقى شيء
امام الاعصار الروسي او هكذا
يقولها الروس. فهل تنجح خططهم